i'm gonna go through some stuff right
now with you guys
um about how you can buy houses
without using any of your own
money if you'd like the sound of that
give me away
okay i'm going to be giving you some
really advanced strategies right now
and honestly these strategies if you put
them to use you're going to be shocked
to what happens because
we talked earlier about property and i
explained to you that when you buy a
house
you're not just going to get paid
you're not just going to get paid with
rent you're also going to get paid
capital appreciation so as the house
value goes
up you're going to get paid in equity
now
cash flow i either rent this
it's fast let's say you get a rent to
rent
or you buy a house and you rent it out
you're going to start getting rent
straight away
this is going to pay the bills nice bit
of income
but what makes you rich is when the
value of the house goes up
the capital appreciation is what makes
you rich
how many you would would actually like
to get very wealthy over the next five
ten years
all right great so the first goal is you
do want to receive some instant income
coming in
that's why i'm such an advocate for
packaging and selling deals
you want to get instant income coming in
if you control a property rather than
owning it that's what ricky's talking
about
and by the way today i'm going to jump
on on the laptop real soon
and you're just gonna you're just gonna
tell me some areas you're gonna be like
samuel
find a rent to rent in um manchester and
i'll boof i'll do it like that
you say samuel find me a lease option
agreement in london
boom i'll do it like that samuel find me
a service accommodation in bristol back
i'll do it and you can shout out the
areas
you can shout out the towns you can give
me the strategy i'll jump online i'll
show you exactly how to do it straight
scratch no preset up nothing so a rent
to rent
is when you just control a property
you're gonna give the landlord a
guaranteed rent
but then you're gonna break the property
up and you're gonna put tenants in the
house
push the rent up and you're benefiting
from cash flow that's a fabulous
strategy i love that we have a training
program called the never use
your own money again program and i'll
never use your own money again
we teach you rent to rent however the
reason ricky prefers lease options and
the reason i've created so much wealth
from lease options
is because you get rent on lease options
and you get capital appreciation as well
let me give you an example there was a
guy who contacted me in 2009
and the guy said to me he said samuel
i've got a house
i'm selling the house for 85 000 pounds
would you be interested in buying the
house now if someone says to you
hey you're interested in buying my house
what are you gonna say you're gonna
you're gonna have some questions right
about the house about the situation yes
or no
all right thank you yeah of course so i
said to steve i said steve
you want 85 000 what's the address
what's the situation
tell me about the situation how much
rent would you get for it what's going
on
and steve tells me the situation he
tells me that he bought the house
for 95 grand he bought it in 2007
for 95 grand he says now it's 2009
and it's dropped in value
now it's 85 grand i said interesting
i said steve what are you renting the
house out for
he said samuel what i'm actually doing
he said i did buy the house for my son
to live in
my son was paying me 450 a month which
to be honest
was below the market value i could have
probably got 550
but i put my son in my son was paying
450
um and i was like okay i said were you
making good profit he said not really
i said did you get have you got a
mortgage he goes yeah i've got a
mortgage i said what's the mortgage on
the property see what i'm doing right
now folks
i'm asking loads and loads and loads and
loads of questions
this is what you need to get good at
most most investors
that start out they'll ring up a
landlord and the landlord will go
so what's your background then how many
properties do you own um why
why are you interested in this house
have you done this before what kind of
tenants will you be putting in
blah blah blah blah blah blah blah and
you the entrepreneur
will be answering the questions trying
to trying to get
prove yourself to the seller or the
agent that's not how things are done on
samuel lee's training
how things are done is you the
entrepreneur or the person
asking all the questions because the
person who's asking the questions
is the person who's in control how many
you're learning something give me a wave
all right so i'm asking steve all these
questions steve says well samuel the
mortgage outstanding
is 81 grand now straight away
straight away i'm thinking
well if the mortgage is 81 grand
that's the mortgage outstanding and all
he wants is 85 grand
well when he sells his house for 85
grand
he's gonna have to pay the solicitors
the estate agent
and pay off the mortgage he's gonna be
left with about
nothing how many understand the
situation
anybody not
okay a couple people not quite sure so
when you here's the thing right
there's something called which is really
important
negative equity it's the only kind of
negativity in my life
i like okay i love negative
equity i don't like negative people i
like negative equity let me explain what
that is
negative equity is very simply where
the outstanding debt on the house the
mortgage
is equal to or greater than the house
value
if the mortgage is more than the house
you're in negative equity
so steve he's not quite in negative
equity but pretty much
he's got no equity in the house so i'll
say to steve well steve
if you're if you if your mortgage is 81
grand and you sell it
and you you're advertising it for 85
i said i mean i mean you're not going to
get much money in your pocket he says i
know yeah
i said well why are you selling it he
said i'm selling it because the house is
empty
my son moved out and i just want to get
rid i'm semi retired and i don't want
the hassle
i said okay i said steve i could maybe
offer you about 72 000 what do you think
i'm an investor i need to make money he
goes samuel i
bought it for 95. now i'm selling it for
85 my mortgage is 81.
i can't drop the price at penny below
81.
if you buy cash tomorrow for 81 i'll
accept it that's the lowest i can go
now let me ask you a question actually
um in fact
can i get can i get someone on screen i
want i want i want to ask someone
something anyone anyone volunteer
can i can i go can i get going then i'll
i'll get um i'll get i'll get um
gibril at the top gibraltar hello what's
happening you okay gibral
yeah yeah you yeah good so all right so
cool how old are you buddy
17. yeah 17.
all right do you understand what
negative equity is
yes explain it to me so negative equity
is when the debt mortgage is equal to or
greater than
the value of the house i love it i love
it okay cool
so if you were steve
right or even i'll ask you ask you this
way if you were advising steve
what do you think the best thing for
steve to do would be
in this situation keep the house
keep it why yeah because if he's selling
it he's not really gonna make any money
so i'd say probably keep it try renting
it out or doing something else with it
all right hey thank you so much you know
what you're absolutely right so
give gibril a hand give him a hand okay
now listen
why do i get jabril to say that because
if a 17 year old property investor
can clearly see that hey just keep it
how many of you think that you should
just keep it keep getting the rant
and and wait for it to go up in value
yeah give me a wave okay
now here's the problem with trying to do
clever clever deals
lease options and rent to rents if i try
and pitch him on a lease option
agreement right now
he's going to get resentful he's gonna
be like oh man i might just keep it so
what i'm gonna say to steve and what i
say every time
i said to steve i said steve first
things first what are your mortgage
payments each month
he says 145. i said right so steve you
told me that your son was paying you 450
but that was a cheap rent you could have
got 550 he said yes sir
i said then why don't you put another
tenant in
and keep receiving your 400 pound a
month
it's a terrible time to sell the
property
just hold on to it it's going to go back
up but samuel i don't want to be a
landlord
i don't want to keep it i don't want
this i'm worried about this blah blah
blah my wife wants to sell it
you see here's the thing some people
make decisions based on emotions and not
logic
even some of you guys when i made the
offer i was like hey you know
995 deal selling masterclass some of you
were like
oh man i don't know and maybe you're
fearful and your fear stopped you taking
action
even though your logic was like it
actually does make sense
how many you know i'm talking about give
me a wave give me a wave
and it's the same way steve he knows the
best thing to do logically is you just
take action
to rent it out to keep it but his
emotions his
fear his fear his wife
his upbringing is just like i just don't
want it i bought it for my son to live
in it
and my son's moved out and now i'm upset
and i'm emotional and i just want to
get rid of the house now if steve wants
to get rid of the house and he's
emotional
i'm offering steve to keep it he doesn't
want to keep it so i just said to steve
i said steve
how about this i said how about instead
of me giving you 81 000 for the house
and you taking that 81 grand and
immediately paying off your mortgage
provider
and then you're left with nothing i said
that's okay
that would be good for you but i said i
don't want to give you 81 grand
and to be honest no one wants to give
you 81 grand right now because it's 2009
and the housing market is a bit stiff so
i said how about i'll give you
81 grand but i'll give it you in
seven years to give the market chance to
recover
however right now today
i'll take on complete responsibility of
the property and i'll become the
landlord
and i'll pay the mortgage payments
direct steve
how does that sound now in steve's mind
he's thinking hang on a minute it's
going to
give me no stress easy peasy i'll get
the same money as i want anyway
is it a pretty decent option for steve
do you reckon
pretty decent option however what's
steve going to stay steve's
always always always going to say no
he's not going to want to do it even
though logically for steve it makes
sense he's not going to want to do it
and why is that
it's because of how you word the offer
so here's how you word the offer so
you're going to say steve
i may be able to offer something like
this
i'll buy the property off you for 81 000
pounds
however i'll pay you in seven years time
because we need to give the market
chance to recover
however right now i'll take on the
mortgage
take complete responsibility of the
property and become the landlord
steve how does that sound that's the
closing statement how does that sound
now at this point if you word it just
like that steve's not going to say yes
he's also not going to say no he's going
to have loads and loads of
questions he's going to say well hold on
how does it work can i see a copy of the
contract what
is this list involved what happens if
you don't pay me the mortgage what
happens if this what happens if that
steve's gonna have loads of questions
now at this point when steve has all
these questions
you're gonna say to steve steve
why don't you sleep on the concept
and speak to a solicitor about all your
legal questions
and then give me a call back if you're
interested in going ahead in fact
i've used this listing for deals like
this before his name is xyz sisters
here's his card
have a chat with him anything you need
for me house
here's my email here's my number give me
a call now
it does that sound like a pretty
reasonable proposal from me yes or no
yeah now i offered this to steve
and i'm thinking about it when i get
when i got home i was thinking steve
gonna say yes
you're gonna say no what's gonna happen
steve contacts my solicitor steve calls
me up a week later
he knows more about lease option
agreements than i know
he's literally picked the brain of my
solicitor gone over all the ifs and
butts
he calls me back a week later he says
samuel um you know i'd like to go ahead
with some heads and terms
can we get this can we get this all
drawn up it sounds good
now from steve's perspective 2009
he's having the property just pop off
his hands he's getting his mortgage paid
emotional release of the property from
my perspective
i stick a tenant in on day one
because i market the property before i
even get the keys
i stick a stick a tenant in a 550
fifty a month i'm paying the mortgage of
one four five
that means i'm making four hundred pound
gross profit call it like
call it three three two five after i've
paid my bits and bobs
so i've got like three to five a month
every month
seven years later i have the option
to buy the property for eighty one
thousand pounds and that option
is registered with land registry on the
title dips
seven years later i have the option to
buy it for
81 000 pounds and i'm gonna use
the deposit is gonna be all of those
three
two fives for the last seven years
right because if you look at this look
three two five per month
times twelve i'm getting three thousand
nine hundred a year
times that by seven i got 27 grand
after maintenance management so i've got
27 grand after seven years
so i go back to the house i've got the
option to buy it for 81 grand
now after seven years the house
is worth one two five this is in block
switch by the way warsaw near birmingham
so now i'm buying the house for 81 grand
but it's worth one two five after seven
years
car chains
i'm using the money that i've saved in
deposit money to buy the house
it's a normally done deal the only money
i had to pay down
was a one pound option fee initially to
make this legally binding
and secondly 750 pounds on solicitor
fees
that's it that's my first lease option
agreement
you guys like it ah thank you so much
thank you so much
so that was my first deal now after i
did that deal i'm thinking
maybe i could go do another one maybe i
could go do another one so i started
building my portfolio as a teenager
with lease option agreements and what i
found was
when i started deal selling packaging
and selling deals sometimes i'd come
across a property
and the property might be on there on
the market for 60 grand
and i've noticed that property's been on
the market for ages
and i i'd go around the house i'd say
what are you trying to sell oh we need
to sell is empty we don't want it
anymore
i said okay well i'll buy off if it's 50
000 pounds
i would sell it for fifty thousand but i
can't because of the mortgage i go oh
what's the mortgage
they say the mortgage is sixty i'd go
well hang on a minute if the mortgage is
60 and you've got it on the market for
60
you're not going to make any money when
you sell this property they go i know
it's annoying isn't it okay how about
this
i may be able to offer something like
this i'll buy it off you for 60.
but i'll buy it in seven years to give
the market chance to recover and in the
meantime i'll pay the mortgage how does
that sound
boom like a racket i just start picking
up free houses like this
why would you buy a house and put down a
big deposit
when you can just take it on a lease
option agreement
you've still got your name on the title
dude straight away
you've got the option to bite not the
obligation if it doesn't go up in value
you walk away if it does go up in value
you
absolutely hit the jackpot kachinga
ringa ding
like that's the least option agreement
[Music]